freaking coach on the on the staff every
player better wake up and start start
understanding where we're at have some
personal pride have a freaking sense of
urgency know where we're at have some
pride into who we're playing
for and why we do this
and uh and then and then go find a way
to win as a team
that's my challenge to every single
person in that building this week is
that
and and so uh yesterday was flat out
embarrassing um and and uh our guys know
it i'm not telling you something they
don't know they know it but that
performance yesterday um
is uh is ridiculous and and can't happen
and obviously that starts with
me matt and aggie not happy as he should
be right with the team's performance on
sunday night against the green bay
packers and look this is the bears team
we have seen for the last five weeks
they started five and one it felt like
it was a lot of smoke it was a lot of
mirrors it was a house of cards and the
house of cards has collapsed the past
five weeks their offense stinks
regardless of who's playing quarterback
that's right the issues are too many to
fix on the fly that was something that
nagi alluded to several weeks ago when
they lost to the rams on a monday night
when their defense scored more than
their offense defense seven offense
three you can't just make your offensive
line better like that no you can't get
rid of this guy and replace him with
this guy who do you replace him with
there's nobody out there right you just
have to keep trying to make chicken
salad and sometimes you realize
that your efforts
just end up in chicken stuff
everywhere yeah on every one right and
that's where the bears currently are and
i i
i don't
look i i think he's venting his
frustrations and there's not much he can
do at this point
but
you know the the the the vince lombardi
what the hell is going on out here
speech doesn't work in today's nfl
because uh you either have it or you
don't and the bears don't and you're not
going to all of a sudden find it the
last five weeks of the season no i
you're right about that you're not and
especially on the offensive side of the
ball but i think the one thing that he's
talking about more than anything is
like come on you know there the there
was lack of effort lack of physicality
and just emotion like intensity we
didn't see that from the bears at all on
sunday night i think that's really what
bothered him you know the defense the
way they got pushed around in the run
game and rogers just surgically
destroyed them you know we haven't seen
that from them all year long that's the
first time we saw the defense kind of
asleep at the wheel i'm sure that really
bothered him a lot you know matt nagy
yeah i hate his offense i don't know
what to say i think it's a bad offense i
like him
in a lot of ways as a head coach i do
think he's a good communicator i know
people that know him i know the players
there like him and all those type of
things
they have one big issue i just wish he
would be a head coach if he does get to
keep his job after the year head coach
and you gotta hire an offensive
coordinator like a real offensive
coordinator not somebody that you know
is your buddy who has the same ideas as
you but totally different approach to
your football team and your offense
and that is yes not gonna be fixed to
your point right now and they're just
gonna have to deal with what they got
for now
i don't know that he's gonna get that
choice i know right i don't know he's
gonna have that opportunity i don't know
what's gonna happen after this season i
don't know what's fair i know twelve and
four and eight and eight and now we're
sitting here at five and six and i know
but it's it's you know that's a tough
one to me i don't know where i feel
about that well and because you know
yeah i just i i don't know because
with some of these teams i'm not sure
who's making the decisions and with some
of these teams you've got a team
president
like a ted phillips who is always
insulated who is never scrutinized we
talked about that over the weekend at
pft there was an item that rod wood the
president and ceo of the lions isn't
going anywhere how many chances do you
get
as the person who can say i don't have
anything to do with football when things
are going wrong
but find a way to take credit when
things are going well that drives
general managers and coaches crazy but
that's the best job to have in a
football organization number one because
it pays pretty damn well and number two
you can easily jump under the bed when
the owner is mad about the team sucking
and
then when it's time to make big changes
it's the president
that ultimately is heavily involved in
the search process and the selection
process and at some point
the president fails enough times in
hiring people who can turn things around
that the president has to go so that's
one of the dynamics in chicago what does
ted phillips want and does ted phillips
believe he's got
left in his
bag of equity
another opportunity to say we're going
to hit the reset button here in chicago
so i i i don't know what's fair or what
isn't fair but uh you know to be five
and one and have it all fall apart uh
that that that leaves a mark and that
doesn't look good and uh this year the
dynamics of the pandemic could save the
bears i think some of these teams have
made their moves early yeah in the off
season or during the season so they'll
have more of an opportunity in the off
season to make their hires um i don't
know maybe the fact that they were five
and one maybe that gives them another
right i just i don't know but they need
a quarterback yeah that's what that's
gonna be not nick falls and it's not
mitchell trubisky no you're right it's
not those two need a new offense you
know and i hear you know listen i i talk
on chicago stuff all the time out there
and the regional sports network with nbc
and all that type of stuff i mean yeah
it seems like this is one i would really
think about if i'm
president owner of the bears whatever
about i'm not gonna rush to a decision
because there are things again even with
ryan pace and the bears
i know mitchell trubisky they messed up
he messed that up watson and my homes
are way better let's see he really
messed that up but you know the rest of
the team i don't look at the players and
just go oh it's horrible the defense is
a super bowl defense the offense with
alan robinson and anthony miller and
cole comed and jimmy graham and some of
those guys i mean
it's respectable that's good
so yeah the offensive line's got his
issues there's there so that to me
that's where it's the the debate lies
it's just where like you're saying
where's the blame fall are we going to
be able to fix some of these things in
the off season will matt nagy be open to
hey no more offense for you you got to
bring in somebody totally new i think
those are the conversations chicago
brass would would have to have with that
group there to see where they go
he was the coach of the year two years
ago which should count for something and
they were five and one and you know
maybe he's making the best batch of
chicken salad that he can right
ingredients that have been given to him
but i'm not a big advocate of firing the
gm and keeping the head coach because
then you get everyone off schedule right
the gm's waiting for the chance to hire
his coach and then you get a situation
like in detroit where after two years
you get rid of jim caldwell you bring in
matt patricia patricia can never live up
to caldwell why'd you get rid of
caldwell that never
goes away it's it's very difficult to
have
current coach new gm i can't think of a
time where that's worked and worked well
where the two come together because the
gm always has ideas as to who he wants
to bring in as his head coach
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports